the big difference honestly is that i
was not raised like you or pretty much
anybody else on this planet and at first
people get like take a little like
umbrage at that i'm unique too yes you
are yes you are yes you are absolutely
but if you look at me like kind of a
feral child that was born and raised in
the woods with no real contact with the
outside world except for very select
people that raised all the children to
be super minds what would happen to
these children if they didn't know the
outside world if we did not use their
language if we did not expose them to
really drilling home they were a boy or
a girl or a race or anything they were
just minds
that's me
on twitter it often says some people say
or experts say doesn't that mean we're
supposed to always follow that
information that would be bob in the
coffee room so some people some people
could be you know my uh imaginary friend
like some people gets you away with a
lot of stuff some people is also like so
you feel this way huh well they look at
you
like the only way we're gonna grow and
get better is if like call it what it is
you know just just it's like i've done
it and the world has tried to kill me
yes i almost said c because i live in
america but um you know it is really i
think incumbent on all of us uh to to
just shake we don't have time we're
running out of time so like on that
interview on nightline the last thing
she said and it was like a warning in
this journalist's eye she leans into me
these are very powerful people you're
talking about
and i look at her and i pause
don't underestimate the effect of a good
positive
and i say i know
so am i
and i took that from an army slogan
weirdly that i started thinking about do
you remember back in the day when they
changed it from uh be all you can be
which is you know a great tagline a
great slogan army be all you can be and
then they changed it to an army of one i
was like
hey that doesn't not quite as catchy
right man
but then i started breaking it down and
i was like i started thinking about it
that's about eight years before i set up
the articles to expose weinstein
and i started thinking about it i'm like
an army of one well i can be an army and
i can say i'm an army so i started just
hashtagging rose army i had no army but
i do like the spartans and i really like
their trojan horse idea
so then i had to sound like i was coming
with all sorts of backup
um but it was you know and of course i
was portrayed as she's coming after men
i'm like
believe me there's so many women that
support this structure that you know
like let's take the new governor
everyone's like the first female
governor of new york
uh
she was there so she knew stuff too
you know so
it's a cult takes everybody to support
it it takes a cross-hypnosis and it
takes the gaslighting but the thing is
like what's great about you your viewers
your
people that think differently that look
at it just take your lenses and go a
little bit abstract a little bit above
and look down
and and dissect the situation
and your truth even if it's just you
that knows it that is enough that is
enough for you to be an army of one and
an army of one can then tagline with
other armies other armies and we can
become a massive force and i think
that's beautiful
so that being said as someone that has
you know had the machine try to destroy
them over and over again and who took
down
the most powerful people in hollywood i
mean weinstein specifically what do you
think it is about you like you
specifically that like
allows you to do it and keep going
because everyone that i talk to wherever
i go they're always like oh i want to
speak up more but i have a job or oh i
want to speak more but i have kids or
all of the things that are legit reasons
right they're legit at some level and
then on the other hand
you know they know they have something
inside them that they're holding back
that's feeding it i mean that's the sort
of hypnosis that you're talking about
the the big difference honestly is that
i was not raised like you or pretty much
anybody else on this planet and at first
people get like take a little like
umbrage at that i'm unique too yes you
are yes you are yes you are absolutely
but if you look at me like kind of a
feral child that was born and raised in
the woods with no real contact with the
outside world except for very select
people that raised all the children to
be super minds what would happen to
these children if they didn't know the
outside world if we did not use their
language if we did not expose them to
really drilling home they were a boy or
a girl or a race or an anything they
were just minds
that's me and then overnight you know
got broken up the organization the group
i was in that my father was the leader
of and i got
thrown out into gig harbor washington
and to a
really unattractive military-based
school
boom boom
and in my language in my birth language
english is my third language
and my first um which very few people
other than people in the children of god
know and speak or spoke um
everybody that was not us were called
systemize
wait what what is the
language it's invented but so is yours
no but what's it called
it doesn't have any i don't i don't know
the name it was just what we spoke and
so our word for everybody outside our
walls
we called everybody systemites
and they're not wrong that's the thing
the problem with most cults and why they
don't succeed and why an american cult
as a total cult cannot succeed or any
nation cult cannot succeed both micro
and macro
is because they're formed
i think in a way that
really negatively impacts the reason
those people you're talking about why
they can't get there
um not just kids or jobs and yes you
have to be pretty much selfless and and
willing to take the hits
i but also
i was not
notified at age three or four that i was
a girl and here's what you can't do
we're gonna tie your heinz
we're gonna tie your hands behind your
back with politeness little girl and
we're gonna train you since round age
two three go sit on your uncle's lap
give him a kiss you don't want to give
him a kiss
think about it
then the boys you get put in straight
jackets
around two three have fun getting out of
that for the rest of your life so your
life the systemites everybody that was
not us essentially and the reason why we
didn't succeed the cult i was in that my
father led did not succeed is because he
came from the systemite world
i did not so for me
i have no i have no skin in this game
and all the skin i'm going for broke
because i can because why not and i was
a weird kid sure uh i had like venn
diagrams of like napoleon's battle plans
on my wall with pins alexander the great
but then i'd read like one i'd read like
his writings like napoleon or something
then i'd read like five biographies on
that like that particular battle and i
would just like fared out what the truth
was for me i was always trying to find
the truth and what um but i just like
strategy and and if one of the great
ways that i succeed i've made no money
from my success in terms of you know
slaying
the giant hydra that is the hellscape
we're living in i'm like stay down
you know i need backup like and animals
um but i i i slay dragons why
what else am i doing
at the end of my uh podcast which is
called uh the cultural reset it's gonna
be on sub stack
i end it with why why the [ __ ] not
and you know what sometimes it's fun you
have fun right sometimes we have fun
yeah and people like when i called oprah
lizard you know which i believe is true
um i've always felt that way when i saw
her first on tv when i was small when i
came to the states i'd never seen a
television i didn't know who she was but
i saw her interviewing somebody that was
in an immense amount of pain
and her eyes were like not connected at
all but the words coming out of her
mouth were very soft and soothing
but nothing in the eyes connected and i
was i was like i actually was sorry my
ear thing is having a situation um no
problem
it's i was scared of her that i wasn't
scared of her but i was like
like my ah like i just i've had and
maybe it is because growing up with a
father who was
very good at wiring people's minds he
was very good at it
not always for nefarious reasons but
always for ego reasons i don't have that
ego i just don't um i might um seem
egotistical to some i've certainly been
called that but i think it's also people
are unusual unused to people saying what
they're good at just plainly i also know
what i'm really bad at i suck at quite a
few things i'm also [ __ ] great at a
lot of things so
go from there if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell